I cannot say the title of this
conference byzantium modernism
the slash has an apathetic function it
makes manifest that which is ineffable
in SC rollin Bart's the socialist
analysis of Balzac short story Saracen
Bart rights
hence the slash confronting the s of
Saracen and the Z of San banila has a
panic function it is the slash of
censure the surface of the mirror the
wall of hallucination the verge of
antithesis the abstraction of lib n't
the obliquity of the signifier the index
of the paradigm hence of meaning bart
stateman captures the slash ability to
both unite and to separate the words
which it suspends in silent adjacency as
such the slash between Byzantium and
modernism in our conference title could
be seen as an evasion tactic in our part
a manner of issuing all responsibility
for this conferences findings and
implications if this was our intention
we surely failed a word such as and
would have better served that goal or
quite simply any word instead the slash
is precisely the index of the paradigm
as Bart describes it for Bart of course
the paradigm refers to the structuralist
binary the intervallic space that
separates the signifiers into discrete
parts and thus allows for signification
thus the slash in this instantiation of
the interval points the possibility for
signification since in the act of
materializing that interval the slash
and turn manifests the entire logic of
the structure this interval which the
slash cuts through thus produces a space
where the encounter of byzantium and
modernism is possible and by virtue the
entire structure of this conference it
visually man affects the paradox of
signification before the signifier the
11th century Byzantine philosopher
Michael pizzelles understood the
semiotic power of the interval when he
wrote in his encyclopedic the Omni fire
doctrina that space is according to the
arithmetician z-- the intelligible
interval of numbers like that in between
1 & 2 2 & 3 and so on for since the
order of numbers is not continuous but
set in opposition the intervals between
numbers are named space the cellars
extends this idea with a parallel metal
or to container writing just as the
vessel contains the wine and the wine is
said to be circumscribed the whole body
of the vessel nevertheless does not
receive the wine but only the Hollow
circumference of it
this statement is in pizzelles
encyclopedia the definition for Quora
translatable a space container or land
previously used by Plato to describe the
prototypical medium in the Timaeus Quora
is the receptacle of becoming it is
likened to the Virgin wax upon which the
form of the stamp may be impressed a
metaphor that in Byzantium takes double
meaning in the Virgin's body both
described as the Virgin wax from which
the Christ was formed and as in the
akathistos hymn the container of the
uncontainable a coda Acorah to Cora in
my mind serves as a statement on the
medium of the Incarnation and thus
speaks to the possibility for image
production in the Byzantine world the
icon being dependent on the Incarnation
as the moment where the Divine Presence
condescended to take on human form and
thus allowed itself to be depicted by
colors and line however it also speaks
to the mediation of Byzantine art by an
intervallic space between Byzantium and
modernity a distance which emerges not
in continuity but rather in its
opposition since this 19th century
artists critics and scholars have
utilized the Byzantine as a manner of
articulating the development of
modernity in its image world for example
Roger Fry coined the term proto
Byzantines to describe the
post-impressionists and later Alfred
Barr described Byzantine art and its
iconic heritage as fundamental to the
development of modern art designated as
one of the prototypes and sources
propelling his Torpedo diagram for the
Museum of Modern Art into the future
perhaps most famously these Byzantine
parallels were articulated by Clement
Greenberg in his 1958 article by the
same title which was selected as one of
the essays included in his well known
art and culture vol 4 Greenberg the
Byzantine is not an origin point for the
teleological development of modernity
but instead instead a teleological
parallel the encounter and dialectic
from which a formal logic of modernism
could be derived much of the care
juristic of Modern Art synonymous with
Greenberg's name are discussed in
business in the Byzantine parallels sa
Greenberg writes in late Roman and
Byzantine art the naturalistic Devices
of greco-roman painting were turned
inside out to reaffirm the flatness of
the pictorial space light and shade the
means par excellence of sculpture
illusion were stylized into flat
patterns and used for decorative or
quasi abstract ends instead of
illusionist ones the power of cubism and
a Byzantine mural art alike implies the
wrench and the dialectic by which a long
and rich tradition has reversed its
direction
Greenberg's analysis here speaks
precisely to the drive of analytical
cubism x' articulation of space its
fracturing and superimposition of
pictorial pictorial planes and passage
his article astutely captures the
spatial prolepsis of the byzantine image
the manner in which it spills out into
space and produces what Otto Dimas in
1948 had described as a spatial icon in
the mosaics at Daphne and whose formal
parallels could be seen earlier in the
1915 counter release by vladimir tatlin
that emerged from the logic and display
of the Byzantine icon in its Russian
descendant Greenberg's writing expresses
a prevalent logic and display of the
Byzantine icon in its sorry Greenberg's
writing expresses a prevalent logic of
the formal homologies between Byzantine
and modern art a logic which is likewise
manifested by the neo-byzantine revival
movements of the late and 19th and early
20th centuries a nearby example of this
model may be seen in the formal
resonances between the seventh century
Byzantine mosaics of st. demetrius and
barry Faulkner's intelligence awakening
mankind mosaic from the 1260 avenue of
the americas entrance of the GE building
at Rockefeller Center produced by the
Ravenna mosaics company in 1933 the
necessary question however is how does
one move beyond such formal homologies
or to return to the Cubist example
brought up by Greenberg how does one
deal with the events of October 1912
which included Picasso's creation of
guitar the subsequent advent of the PLA
and thus the beginning of synthetic
cubism what evil and Bois and
Rosalind Krauss have unified under the
title the semiology of cubism while
Clement Greenberg attributed the an
iconic impulse of iconoclasm as an
aesthetic drive the iconoclastic debates
were in fact a semi illogical
controversy and at the risk of sounding
facetious I would consider the art of
the centuries following iconoclasm to be
part of precisely a Samia logical
project centered on the interrelated
problems of space and signification
Byzantine iconoclasm in the 8th 9th and
11th centuries are all centered on
moments in which the signified is
confused with the referent where the
sign is believed to manifest the full
presence of the divinity
instead the ikono files reiterated that
the icon exists as a space of desire not
a full presence not surprisingly Lacan
found resonances to his construction of
the gays and the objet petit ax in the
Pantocrator mosaics at daphne as an
aside I find it telling that Roman
Jakobson recalls that when the Moscow
linguist Circle finally was able to
reach the source general course they
believed that they had already learned
its tenants by their familiarity with
cubism and left to wonder what lessons
had they learned even before that from
the icon their lessons of cubism were of
course
formal based on the constructions of
representation and signification the
Cubist pictorial field I would like to
imagine that had they considered the
function of the icon in Byzantium they
would have been led to the lessons found
in Derrida's yet in existence of gromet
ology where the structure of the sign
depends on difference both the never
adult difference from the other which
the sign signifies and the deferral
encountered in its signification this is
the comprehension of this this is the
comprehension of the sign this compass
Aria this comprehension of the sign is
of course the Orthodox limit of the icon
in Byzantium whereby the image manifests
a directed or present absence the
division of spoken words and written
words depicted in the Rockefeller Center
mosaic speaks the division between
speech and writing here unified by its
signified thought however it also
directly addresses the rise of
technologies that allow for
dissemination of knowledge namely radio
given its location in the entry to the
then Radio Corporation of America or I
see a building
the Byzantine in its formal and
conceptual parallels has served in
Greenberg's words as the wrench and the
dialectic in articulating the rise of
new median technologies
this is perhaps most vividly
demonstrated in two portraits of
Marshall McLuhan that depict him with a
book open to the mosaic programs of
Hagia Sophia carefully staged these
images draw primary importance to the
Byzantine and McLuhan's conception of
new media and the global image comparing
these two other portraits of McLuhan the
Byzantine comparing these two other
ports of McLuhan the Byzantine seems to
mediate the virality and feedback of the
technological image or at least as its
prehistory which McLuhan as the great
image theorist of this moment pours over
as if in the midst of his research
however such an image begs us to
question whether this is merely an
idiosyncratic or passing reference and
furthermore what is the place of the
Byzantine icon in relation to modernity
'he's new media and technology this
interest in Byzantium continued well
into the 1990s as demonstrated in the
promotional copy of Billy Idol's 1990
charmed life album designed by Randall
Martin the cover features an image of
Billy Idol as an icon with silver
revetment a manifestation of the icon
seen in Byzantium and particularly in
the post Byzantine Russian world in
conversations with its designer Martin
explained to me that the cover
originates from seeing silver covered
icons on sale and Fifth Avenue in New
York in the late 80s the icon cover was
a clever play on Billy Idol's name and a
spoof of the Gothic fascinations of punk
rock albums in the 80s whose imagery
conveyed visions of a loud fiery hell at
the time Martin wrote in our exchange
computers were just starting to be used
for graphic design and like the Arts and
Crafts movement reacting to modernism I
was interested in creating images that
were obviously handmade I find his
deployment of the icon an interesting
choice as a site of resistance against a
computer made mechanical image here we
find an articulation of the icon that
strives not for being perceived as an
image not made by human hands the Ocado
poet on of Byzantium or as manifesting
the divine presence that is beyond the
skill and craft of the artist as the
notion of MC ghost Gaddafi or insult
painting articulated itself from my
Celes here the icon in its silver rep is
a materiality embodies the hand of the
artist that which works against the
modern medium nevertheless upon opening
of this cover by stripping the icon of
its revetment the image of the idol
reveals the double bind implicit in this
artifact the divinity of the image is
not found in via analog production of
illusionistic revetment but rather in
the shimmering light of the digital halo
the CD that pokes through that which
contains the sonic presence of idol
serves as the halo of the photographic
image as such this object reveals
attentions of our recent past
articulated through the Byzantine at
once it is an act of defiance of
resisting new media new ideas and new
systems of belief through an allusion to
analog artistic productions while also
revealing the mysterious and quasi
divine workings of digital
representation the case is similar with
Andy Warhol's gold Marilyn Monroe from
1962 where Marilyn is depicted as an
icon after her death the work manifests
a Byzantine iconicity articulated
through the rhetoric of 15 minutes of
fame Hollywood film studios and the
devotional following of the cult figures
celluloid image parallel tensions can be
seen in contemporary images from pop
culture such as a Byzantine icon of Luke
photoshop's with the image of Rick
Santorum on the Colbert show recently or
my favorite the Byzantine izing Theodora
like headdress of Lady gaga as she Jesus
and the twelve apostles ride on a Los
Angeles freeway in the opening of her
2011 music video Judas these images
speak at first glance the Byzantines
association with iconicity and celebrity
the religious and the secular and the
tensions which such systems create
however they also speak to a
contestation over the ideological
terrain enacted by the icon the
terrestrial rule of the image in a
digital world where repetition and
virality open new epistemic areas of
artistic production I wish to conclude
with an image from Anselm Kiefer 1980
iconoclastic controversy series in this
picture
tanks bearing the names of the
iconoclastic emperors and patriarch of
Byzantium are seen closing upon a
circumscribed terrain inscribed with the
names of eighth and ninth century
konna file theologians and imperial
members Kieffer's work struggles with
post-world War two trauma and memory
particularly in Germany in this image
the painter / palette becomes a space of
the image contestation the receptacle of
the images becoming or simply Cora in my
mind in sketching any introduction to
Byzantium modernism I was destined to
fail or to make vulgar claims against
the subjects I wish to represent the
internal conference devoted to the /
this failure was both inevitable and
necessary in the days that follow it is
necessary to ask how we construct a
discursive space between Byzantium
modernism how the enduring re-emergence
of the Byzantine plays into the
narratives of modernity and its art and
consider what both modernism and
Byzantium have to gain from this mutual
translation thank you